[音楽]
[拍手]
はじめまして立教大学法学部4年生の
桃瀬康平です
まず僕がどんな人間かをお伝えするために
簡単に自己紹介をします
生まれは埼玉で高校入学のタイミングで
北海道に引っ越しました高校
卒業後
浪人をして1年間
必死に勉強をして
偏差値を25上げてここに入学しました
入学後ボランティアサークルに入り
途上国に家を建てる活動に3度参加しまし
た
3度目は
リーダーを務めました
活動には
約25万円かかるのですが
居酒屋でアルバイトをして
活動費を自分で稼いでいました
この中では人生で初めて小説を書いて
コンクールに応募しましたそしたら入賞
することができました
そして今学生生活の締めくくりとしてここ
に登壇させてもらっています
突然ですが皆さんは自分のことを特別な
存在だと自覚できていますか
特別とは他と違うこと
ですまた人はみんなそれぞれ全く違います
つまりどんな個人も特別な存在のはずなん
ですですがそんなに単純には自分のことを
特別だとは自覚できません
若者の自己肯定感の低下なんて言葉を聞く
ようにもなりました
自分が他と違う存在であることを自覚すれ
ばいいだけなのにどうも自分を特別だとは
思えない自分が何者かわからない自分が
何者でもないことが
辛い
漠然と特別な誰かになりたいこんな苦しみ
を抱いたことがある人もしくは
抱いている人いませんか
このような苦しみがなぜ生まれてしまうの
でしょうか
僕は僕たちが生きている時代そしてその
価値観に原因の一つがあると思います
今の時代の価値観として広く共有されて
いるのは多様性の尊重です
例えば女は女らしく家事をしろ男は男
らしく働けこういった
らしさの押し付けはもう古い価値観です
これからはその人らしさを尊重する時代
です
また多様性が尊重される価値観の中では
様々な生き方が
肯定されます
以前までは
競争に勝っていい大学に行っていい会社に
勤めてというのが
幸せの価値観としてありましたが今の時代
は
幸せの形は人それぞれ
競争に勝つことが
幸せとは限らないそういう価値観が広まっ
ています
その人の生き方はその人が決めるべきです
しその人の選んだ生き方が尊重されること
はとても素晴らしいことです
ですがこの価値観は素晴らしいとしても
この多様性の尊重が今の時代特有の新たな
苦しみを生んでいると僕は思います
らしさの押し付けや
競争は生きづらさを生みますが少し
視点を変えれば自分の役割や立ち位置を
示してくれるものでもありました
これらがあったかつての世代は世界がある
程度自分のことを定義してくれるそんな
時代だったと言えると思います
その反面その人らしさが尊重される現代は
自分が何者であるかを自分で定義しなけれ
ばいけない時代そんな時代であると言える
のではないでしょうか
そんな現代はみんな違ってみんないいんだ
という素晴らしい
価値観を共有しつつあるはずなのですが
そこには常にあなたはどう違ってどういう
のかあなたは何者なのかあなたはどう特別
なのかそう問われているようなそんな
苦しみがあります
そんな中で特別な存在として
輝いて見えるのはこのような人たちでは
ないでしょうか
特別な才能
経験
環境
肩書きを持つ人特別な活動をしている人
社会や他者に
価値提供をしている人
人生をかけて何かに熱中している人
このような人たちはとても輝いていて特別
な存在のように思えます
またそんな現代ではSNSが大きな影響力
を持っていますが
SNSでは特にこのような人たちが目立ち
たくさん目に入ります
そして
身近な人たちもつぶやきます
起業したボランティアした大会で優勝した
留学した
輝いていて特別な存在のように思える人
たちがすぐ身近にもいるのだということを
感じます
そうするとみんなすごいなやはりあなたは
道徳別なのかあなたは何者なのかそう問わ
れているような苦しみが僕を襲います
僕には何もない
そういう
劣等感に苛まれるん
ですここまで他人事のように話してきまし
たがこれは僕の話です
このトークは僕が僕を救うためのトークで
もあるん
です突然ですが自己紹介をやり直させて
ください
埼玉から北海道に引っ越しました
親の転勤が理由での引っ越しで地元の埼玉
を離れるのが本当に嫌で
最悪な運命だと思っていて中学の卒業式で
は大泣きしてしまいました
ですが今振り返ると最高な運命でした高校
で優しい友人たちに囲まれたことで優しい
人間になりたいという僕の人生の軸が
決まりました
浪人して
偏差値を25上げました
受験勉強を頑張ろうと思ったのは
劣等感からでし
た運動が苦手で
絵が苦手で
歌を歌うのも苦手で何をやっても人より
少し劣っていて何の才能もないそんな自分
がずっとずっと嫌でした
結果を残したこともなかったので
肩書きが欲しい結果が欲しいとその一心で
受験勉強を始めました
晴れて第一志望のここに入学できたわけな
んですが
立教生であるとか
偏差値を上げたといった
肩書きや成果よりもこんな僕でも1年間
頑張ることができたんだというその事実の
方がよっぽど僕が僕を受け入れる理由に
なっていました
途上国に家を建てる活動をしていました
海外ボランティアしていますなんて言うと
優しいねとか
就活に有利だもんねとかよく言われました
でも実際はそんな理由ではないです
僕自身ボランティアとして見ず知らずの人
のため人のためにただ働きをするそんな人
の気持ちが心底わからなくて
わからなすぎて興味を持って
それでやってみたら何かわかるかもしれ
ないそう思ったのがきっかけでし
たこの活動を続けたのは
チームでするこの活動がただただ面白かっ
たからです
人生で初めて書いた短編小説が入賞しまし
た
小説はずっと書いてみたかったんですが
自分の才能の無さを突きつけられるのが
怖くてずっと挑戦できずにいました
この時に書いたのは
友人が誘ってくれたからでした
実際に書いてみてプロの小説家の人って
本当にすごいんだなと思って落ち込んだり
もしたんですがそれでも小説を書く事って
こんなに楽しんだとそう気づくことができ
ました
ちなみにこの入賞したコンクールというの
はごくごく小規模のものです
テレックス立教友登壇しています
断ることに他人と比較をして
劣等感に苛まれてしまうそんな自分を救う
ために
登壇しました
この肩書きよりもこのトークの内容やこの
経験が僕を救うことを期待しています
そしてもちろん聞いてくださっている皆様
にとっても何か少しでも救いがあれば
嬉しいと思っていますはじめの自己紹介
より僕のことが伝わってくれていると
嬉しいです
初めの自己紹介は僕の外面
肩書きの羅列でしかありませんでした
本当のところあんなものでは人のことは
わからないんだと思います
大学生活を通してたくさんの人とそれなり
に深く関わっていく中で気がついたことが
あります
それはその人の特別性やその人らしさは
その人の内面にあるということです
人の外面とは
肩書きや
成果などの他人が簡単に定義評価できる
ものです
人の内面とはその人が何を感じ何を考える
か
です他人が外から簡単に評価することは
できません
僕がこのような人たちを特別な存在だと
認識するときそれは
肩掛けや成果などを根拠にしていて外面
しか見ていませんでし
たあなたは何者かあなたはどう特別なのか
そう問われているようなそんな苦しみの
正体は
他人から特別だと思われる自分になりたい
という思いでし
たしかし
才能があるから特別な人
夢を追っているから特別な人
成果を出しているから特別な人
そんな考え方がそもそも間違いなのでは
ないか
今の社会人は簡単に定義評価できる人の
外面を中止してしまっていると思います
だから自分やその人にしかない内面にある
特別性を見失ってしまいます
自分の内面にある特別性を自覚する前に
他人から特別だと思われる自分になりたい
そう考えて行動をすることもあるかもしれ
ません
人にはみんな内面があります
たとえ同じ景色を見ていても人それぞれ
感じること考えることが違います
それが僕たちが唯一無二の特別な存在で
あるという根拠なのではないか
特別な
才能
経験
環境
肩書きがなくても特別な活動をしていなく
ても
社会や他者に価値貢献していなくても
何かに熱中していなくても僕もあなたも
特別な存在なん
です苦しみが
完全には消えないとしても今日これが言い
たくて僕はここに立っています
僕もあなたも
唯一無二の内面を持つ特別な存在なん
です指令ごとだとしても僕はそう言い続け
たいです
僕はこんなことを考えている人間です
あなたは何を感じ何を思い何を考えますか
教えてください以上ですありがとうござい
まし
[拍手]